The neck tie has its roots in military history.
For starters, a collection of terracotta sculptures
discovered in 1974 in Xian, China gives insight
into the style worn by Chinese soldiers over
a thousand years ago.
China’s first emperor, Qin Shih Huang, wanted
his army to be buried with him as his guardians
in the afterlife.
Lucky for all the soldiers involved, his advisers
convinced him instead to have life sized replicas
of his troops made to be used as his protectors
throughout eternity.
In 210 BC when he died, his terracotta “army”
was buried with him in this way.
Each statue wore a wrapped neck cloth, the
earliest known predecessor of the modern tie.
Yet Qin Shih Huang’s army seems to have
been the only known Chinese wearers of the
neck cloth.
There are no known representations of Chinese
soldiers or Chinese people in general wearing
this piece of clothing outside of this at
this time.
So historians believe that these neck ties
might might have been used here more or less
as a badge of honor for Qin Shih Huang’s
army.
The neck tie is also depicted in Trajan’s
column in Rome, Italy.
Emperor Trajan ruled the Roman Empire from
98 to 117AD.
He was regarded as a military genius and was
responsible for the greatest expansion of
the Roman Empire.
His military conquest of Dacia is commemorated
in Trajan’s marble column erected around
113 AD, where thousands of soldiers are shown
wearing various styles of neckwear.
Again, as was the case with the Chinese, there
is no record of other Roman soldiers wearing
neckties at this time.
Thus, some think that it was also a sign of
honor befitting exceptional fighters.
During the middle ages, another example of
the necktie was worn in a military setting.
In the early 1630s, during the Thirty Years
War, Croatian soldiers in support of France
were presented to the French King Louis XIII.
The Croats wore colorful, knotted neckerchiefs
as a part of their uniform which attracted
their French partners who were accustomed
to wearing starched, ruffled collars.
Apart from its decorative purpose, the necktie
was more practical than these stiff collars
and could protect the soldiers’ shirts and
buttons.
By the time Louis XIV came to the throne,
these ties became fashionable in France.
Military personnel, French courtiers, and
ordinary French people began sporting the
accessory in various colors and fabrics.
Some people even believe that “cravat”,
the French word for “tie”, was even just
a corruption of “Croat”, as the style
was adopted from the Croatians.
Though the cravat is regarded as the true
forerunner to the modern tie as a fashion
statement, it would take a few hundred years
for the tie to evolve to the narrow strip
of cloth we think of today as a neck tie.
The fancy cravat made its way to England after
Charles II reclaimed the throne in 1660.
Other aristocrats who had lived in exile in
Europe followed him and took along the cravat
which became a fashion rage that also spread
to the English colonies.
The neckwear grew to be a stylish accessory
for the well dressed gentleman who wore it
in every imaginable color and style.
There were cravats of tasseled strings, ruffled
collars, ribbon, embroidered linen, cotton,
and an abundance of lace.
The trend continued into the eighteenth century
when donning a cloth around a man’s neck
became immensely popular among all men regardless
of status.
Towards the end of that century, wearing a
black cravat was considered the height of
fashion.
In 1815, the French Emperor, Napolean Bonaparte
who typically wore black, wore a white cravat
during the battle of Waterloo to honor the
Duke of Wellington who favored that color
during battle.
It was also around that time that people began
to refer to a cravat as a “tie” for the
first time, of course referring to the fact
that the cravats were tied around the neck.
Variety in ties, innovation, and complexity
in knots were the order of the day.
Books and pamphlets were written about the
subject.
In 1818, The Neckclothitania was published,
using satire to make fun of the elaborate
cravat styles.
In 1828, H. Le Blanc wrote The Art of Tying
the Cravat demonstrated in sixteen lessons
including thirty two different styles.
The industrial revolution from the eighteenth
to nineteenth century was the catalyst that
led to the necktie as we know it today.
“White collar” workers of the day sought
comfort and simplicity over previously excessively
elaborate dress.
Stiff, fancy, hard to tie neckties had no
place on the factory floor.
Men tied their neckwear four-in-hand allowing
for a knot at the throat with two ends of
fabric trailing down.
This method of tying was a much less intricate
way of creating a knot than was necessary
when wearing a cravat, and the knot remained
secure.
It remains a popular way of tying a tie to
this day.
Around this time also, the idea of wearing
a tie to show one’s affiliation developed.
In 1880, the first school tie was fashioned
when a member of Oxford University rowing
club removed the ribbons from his boater hat
and tied them four-in-hand.
The trend caught on and ties for various affiliations
developed.
In the 1880s, the ascot tie became the standard
for formal morning dress.
It was made a famous fashion item by Britain’s
King Edward VII, also known as Bertie, who
wore it to the horse races and his subjects
followed.
The name is derived from one of the most celebrated
horse racing events in England, The Royal
Ascot.
The ascot, tie or “bow tie” are still
today regarded as choices for morning dress.
It was and is still typically decorated with
a pin.
By the 1920s, the tie was to evolve even more
drastically when Jesse Langsdorf, a New York
tie maker, cut the fabric at a forty five
degree angle using a three piece construction.
The gist of it is that this allowed the tie,
when tied in standard knots, to drape evenly
without twisting, and gave us the modern look.
Since then, over the years the width of the
tie has expanded and shrunken; the length
has grown and shortened; and colors and designs
have become brighter and softer, but despite
those changes, the style remains substantially
the same.
The modern tie is even generally manufactured
in the same basic way developed by Langsdorf.